What we have here is four different values
some of them expressed with negative numbers
or absolute value, and what I want to do is sort
them from least to greatest, where the least is on
the left and the greatest is on the right. So sort
from least to greatest.
And like always, I encourage you to pause the
video and try to work through it on your own.
So assuming you have, you had a try at it,
so the easiest way I can think about it, well let's
just, let's just plot them all on a number line.
And you might want to draw it out or eventually
you kind of have a number line in your head,
and you can think about it that way.
So let's first think about the absolute value of
value of -27. So what is the absolute value of -27?
Well it's just going to be +27. This right over here
is the same thing as +27, because -27 is 27 to the
left of 0. 27 to the left of 0.
So let's plot the absolute value of -27.
Well it's really 27, so it's going to be right
over here. So that is the absolute value of
-27. It is +27. Alright, then we have -17.
Well, -17, let's see each hash mark here is
3, so this is -9 and -12, -15. So -17
is gonna be right around there.
So that is -17.
And then we have -28.
So we have -27 and each hash mark is 3, so -28
is going to be right over there. -28.
And then finally we have -22.4.
So let's see, we have 18, 21, 22 would be here, so
22.4 is going to be roughly right over there.
So that is 22.4.
So if we want to sort it from least to greatest,
well, we just have to start at the left end
of the number line.
The smallest of them, or the least of them,
is -28. Then we go to -17. -17.
Then we go to 22.4. Then we go to 22.4.
And then we go to the absolute value of -27,
and we are done.